in America in Boulder City with the
annual Danbury parade Victoria Saha was
there for the fun and tells us why
families make it a tradition to come out
every year no matter how hot it gets
even in these hot summer times people
are out here decked out in their red
white and blue for the annual Boulder
City Fourth of July parade take a look
it seems like the whole town is here
this morning showing up here early
grabbing their favorite spot to get the
best view of these floats here and
showing off their American Pride
celebrating America's birthday with a
town ready to party I'm 85 years old I
sit out in the sun Darlene Medina and
her family have been coming to the
Boulder City 4th of July parade for 40
years oh the people the the kids and the
playing and the The Waiting of the flag
they're America they're America they
really are Americanized here it's so
awesome to live here and see this
everybody is just full of uh friendship
family and and you can't ask for a
better place or better people
not only is Boulder City celebrating
independence day but it has something to
celebrate too it's their 75th year of
hosting the 4th of July Danbury parade I
do this every year it's one of my
favorite holidays so yeah we come and
represent and cheer on everybody and
it's just what we do no matter how hot
we come out every summer as long as
we're here in town and it's amazing we
asked parade goers what it means to them
to be American it's the greatest country
in the world everything I like
Freedom ribs happy Fourth of July
it has been a full day in Boulder City
and the celebration keeps going the
fireworks set to begin at 9pm this
evening